you know you've had yet by me new
listings is a complicated thing if
you've written on Chomsky you know that
there is what are called the 15 levels
from sorry the 15 rules for the deep
structure of a language Chomsky says
that not only all known languages will
follow these rules but all possible
languages will follow these rules
because if it doesn't follow these rules
it's not rationally every interval I
mean how is it that we can recognize an
infinite number of sentences that we've
never heard before how is it that we can
tell sense from nonsense almost
instantly even in areas where we have no
real experience syntax it seems to me
the world is made of syntax in some way
that we are that is very slippery one of
the things I think about a fair bit
that's sort of hard to articulate but
that comes out of my ruminations of all
of this is I've noticed that life is
more like a story than it is like
physics and chemistry that you know a
rationalist will tell you while you live
your life and it's ruled by chance and
coincidence and you do what you can and
then they plant you but what it really
seems to be as lived is like a table we
are all inside some kind of a literary
construction of some sort and the things
that happen to us matter they matter and
we are all being led toward something
it's like we're all in some enormous dr.
Zhivago sized novel called I don't know
the 20th century or something and things
have a plotted miss a design that
shouldn't be there if this is really the
world
probabilistic Athens flinging themselves
through space that science tells us this
world is why does it seem so much like a
work of art sometimes like our mobile
broadcasting radio station and the words
that we use are also transmitted
telepathically and it sort of creates
this auric field that creates our
reality yes we all agree I think or it's
well understood in our circles that
language men's reality the obvious
question then is so how come the world
isn't the way I want it and this tension
between we make the world but the world
isn't exactly the way we want it to be
and why is that I'm sure I learned last
night and I don't think anybody
understood what I was talking about but
I sit since New Year's I've been trying
to figure out if I'm dead or not that's
because the message I'm getting from
life is that I'm in heaven you know I
mean things are running so smoothly that
I'm wondered no was I struck by
lightning late in December and didn't
notice it something and I slowly and
gently uncovering the fact that I've
been dead for weeks and that explains
why things are so much fun and why
everything seems to be working so
perfectly because before that it was
[ __ ] on a stick for a long time
[Music]